mr. Spock I haven't done anything like
this in years if it isn't I'm just right
I could blow the entire communication
system it's very delicate work sir
I have had letters and have met and come
in contact with young women who have
said to me I was at a point in time when
I just really wanted to give up I was at
a point in time when I thought the hell
with the world there's nothing there for
me I can think of no one better equipped
to handle it mrs. rora and you came on
and I thought my god there's somebody
there representing me I'm there in the
future it's it was a rare opportunity to
be involved with the show like Star Trek
and so with that goes a responsibility I
think when people react to you in that
kind of way and it's a responsibility to
keep that positive I've told you what
you must do you have only your trust in
me to help you decide to do it you know
this is one of the few shows that take
place in the future that I saw as a kid
was there are any black people you know
lieutenant Aurora was there that gave me
a lot of hope it's very important that
the future be hopeful and that's what
this is I think there's something about
about this show about Star Trek that
really touches a nerve with people it's
a hopeful vision he expects that we will
survive ourselves and make it to the
24th century he assumes that we will
solve all problems of race and sex
prejudice and discrimination we don't
always agree we have some damn good
fights in fact but we always come away
from them with a little better
understanding and appreciation of each
other these are the kinds of people who
seem to have gotten over a lot of their
prejudice though there are still
problems you know different any time
people run into something that is
different or unusual they're a little
scared of it but there are there's so
much that people have learned by the
24th century you notice that there is no
problem between delegating
responsibility between men and women
there's no color problems and I mean
things are going well for the world
these are our pictures of ourselves that
are comforting and ones that we like to
experience and so people love Star Trek
it it reminds them of a part of us that
is that has high ideals that has that
aspires to the highest of what it means
to be a human being we are no longer on
the eve of battle even so I come to ask
myself the same question that young
soldier asked the general all those
years ago how do I defeat fear it's a
lot of firsts we're doing our best to
uphold the legacy that is Star Trek
which is boldly only right the generals
answer the only way to defeat fear is to
tell it no you know on a personal level
it means that we're sending a message to
young people into every one that not
only have LGBT people always been a part
of our culture but that they will always
be a part of our culture and and you
know what's exciting about this
relationship is that we're not making a
big deal about it
it's just a matter of fact and the the
love really stems from their respect and
admiration for each other's genius no
we will not take shortcuts on the path
to righteousness no we will not break
the rules that protect us from our
basest instincts no we will not allow
desperation to destroy moral authority
you know it is important for the younger
girls to see and be able to think you
know what I can be a captain and it
doesn't matter just be good at what you
do right
there's nothing should stop you for
wanting to be a scientist or an engineer
those days out the window we have to be
torchbearers casting the light so we may
see our path to lasting peace we will
continue exploring discovering new
worlds new civilizations I think if you
want to actualize anything you have to
to be able to see it and so just show
people what they really look like to be
an actual mirror to what our society
looks like is a really big deal like
today we're fighting for gender equality
and empowerment of women and that's what
when we fight today in the future we
will have it to know that you know we
have achieved that in the future just to
just see an example of that achievement
is it's I I don't think it can be
measured yes that is the United
Federation of Planets and who we will
always
[Music]